nathalie wolf il fallait reprendre
décrions du pape yves 30 des notes parce
que là on va donner des conseils
formidable pour faire des cadeaux noël
pour lire pour soi même avec deux
invités vinciane québec pour joutes vous
êtes libraire à versailles est libre et
le livre bleu 7 rue de montreuil le
trail du ventoux et vous allez nous
parler de deux petites maisons d'édition
qui font des choses absolument
formidables qui sont les éditions
thibert et d édition et plus exactement
j'avais envie de vous partager avec vous
ces deux petites maisons d'édition qui
font de du livre un objet à la fois
moderne surprenant et intemporel donc je
vais vous parler d'abord de l'édition
vous
regardez les jean charles lajoie dit
bonjour bonjour vous êtes éditeur des
éditions la joie dit vous êtes non
spécialistes plutôt de paula mais pas
que voilà détaille arm est paru aux
éditions élèves voilées de parler de
livres qui ont pour auteurs d d d auteur
un peu particulier qui ont eu des
métiers particuliers entre autres voilà
entre autres de deux anciens un flic un
gendarme et qui ont été attaché de
sécurité intérieure dans des ambassades
de france donc sont quand même des
métiers très particulier et du coup ils
en ressortent des livres avec pas mal de
guilde vécu l d'anecdotes et il ya du
vrai y'a du lourd ailleurs assez de
lieux puis d'autres conseils de la
lecture et de cadeaux d'ailleurs
exactement pour noël alors facile donc
on va commencer avec vous avec ses deux
maisons d'édition donc je vous présente
la maison d'abord d'édition de lait pur
qu'ils soient qui a travaillé en fait
une maison qui existe depuis 30 ans qui
travaille le livre de cuisine comme
comme des bonbons finalement ce sont des
des petites des petites pastilles qu'on
peut prendre en tout cas cette série là
en particulier avec des thématiques très
particulière vous avez le foin le curry
japonais mais aussi des choses très
surprenante le nuage avec dix façons de
préparer le nuage mais là
c'est juste les couvertures ou cd livres
ça ça c'est les vivres et mais je vous
en prie vous regardez vous pouvez
regarder vos
mains dans le nuage vous avez et vous
parle du nuage de la culture autour du
nuage et il ya vraiment des recettes a
préparé avec l'onu à new york il ya la
bastille vichy il ya des choses très
classique le brocoli ou le kaki mais
vous avez le nuage le champagne le
travail est fait à la fois sur le papier
avec un papier qui a étudié qui est 100%
français et ce sont des livres c'est à
l'ancienne parce que vous devez aussi
participé à découvrir
ce n'est pas un défaut vous voyez il ya
chaque papier et étudier chaque
composition toujours en collaboration
avec un spécialiste de la thématique et
y en a toute une petite collection qu'on
peut enfin voilà il ya plein de choses à
faire on peut on peut faire des choses
la friture
des idées de cadeaux des idées de
soixante exactement la citronnelle le
foin
voilà donc il ya aussi des choses autour
de la mer enfin c'est vraiment des
petites pépites et livres d'art et les
recettes marche vraiment
la ville à stevie g accord pouvait
refaire les recettes de la plasticité du
cerveau chez savage 9 euros
de recettes de nuages bas voilà y'a pas
plus léger non mais on peut prendre un
repos pendant quelques heures à vous
pouvez en prendre en cas d'autres tables
ou faire la petite collection je suis
lesbienne collection et puis
exactement vous pouvez ramener ses
gardes et un peu plus coquin il y en a
aux yeux ma cg vous je me doutais que ça
allait bien vous
ayez après on a cette édition les
éditions thibert
qui travaillent en fait à remettre en
avant des grands noms de la littérature
qui sort très peu de titres et qui
travaille vraiment comme de tout cela
sont des purs l'ensemble de la chaîne on
retrouve un très beau un très bel
ouvrage
travailler avec les imprimeurs ans dans
le vernis dans le dans la pose de ceux
de tissus est donc là on a regagné
préjugés qui a été revu et corrigé dont
qui demande aux illustrateurs
d'interpréter en fait leur vision de ses
classiques et de ces grands noms de la
littérature dame ou sommes donc là c'est
mardi le texte et le texte avec des
illustrations de margaux motin qui sont
absolument superbes avec un travail sur
le papier voyez chaque page est
illustrée et voilà quand vous lisez
votre roman vous avez marre comme
hautain qui apporte sa vision du texte
vous avez également les hauts de
hurlevent qui ont été refait avec
nathalie novi sad
vertu est super chaque livre et chaque
artiste apporte une vision de ce roman
qui est un roman classique mais d'une
modernité incroyable à scander madame
donc il peut être lu par des enfants
comme par des adultes aux faits exacts
et peut même plus dans une
classification
exact jeunesse et adulte crois que tout
le monde que voilà un service les actes
alors y'a jenner aussi de charlotte
brontë toujours aussi par ned et nino
vie
voilà et chaque voyez que on ressent
aussi l'ambiance du livre par cette
petite
épargne et d'illustrations qu'elle
abaisse prolifique avec des dessins et
djen djen austin avait été fait par
moments le margaux motin sur deux titres
donc enfin que je pense qu'un à d'autres
raisons et charlie sentiments et
organise préjugés et celui-là ça c'est
des routeurs le vent a cédé aux demandes
de nathalie novi et il ya de littérature
française de dos alors donc dans ce
domaine publication eh ben pour
l'instant je pense pas mais je vais
peut-être suggéré d'en faire
mais oui c'est vrai qu'ils ont traduit
beaucoup de de vraiment anglais
effectivement ils n'ont pas de
littérature française pour l'instant
mais qu'ils y travaillent je pense
qu'ils travaillent et dans le présentoir
cette fois évincée tous les titres
donnés pur à oui toujours bah oui
beaucoup couru attendait d'eux
racontez-nous ce qu'il y ait le feu par
exemple oui le feu le zaatar les
invisibles aux attar c'est quoi c'est
une épice de glisse le foin allez-y
l'oeil à bras le yaourt en caviar
français voilà dix façons de préparer la
trévise la langue aux
mêmes trucs des cannibales
non pas forcément
mais ça parle de tout en fait ça parle
de ce que va être le coeur dans la
culture mais aussi
le coeur le sang la langue en fait ils
font ils sont proches du polar regarder
ça la queue
[Rires]
et vous voyez tout effet tout est
réfléchi aussi bien dans la couleur du
papier dans la typographie on va on est
sur l'ensemble de la chaîne du livre
dans les deux cas en fait ils mettent en
avant à la fois le travail d'impression
le travail de l'éditeur le travail de
graphiste le travail même du papier
parce que ferez-vous de trucs sur la
queue à la recette c'est long en bouche
il ya un travail de munitions cette
visite à mlle manque à feu de leurs
faivre de ses pensées là jusqu'au bout
et c'est du circuit court ouais c'est
exactement salade de papaye verte
une autre scène de que valent mieux
qu'une
[Rires]
oui qu'elle disait le disais c'est de çà
peut être qu'aucun
je suis maître le bois je reprends le
tout-paris chanter et danser enfin voilà
la friture par exemple regarder sur
papier doré qui rappelle la friture
la trevis à m saddam
crème frites c'est bon ça
c'est une réussite c'est marrant parce
que
je disais ce genre de livre on les
trouve donc pas donc des
pinces dans les librairies indépendantes
les libraires curieux les libraires qui
ont envie de proposer autre chose que
les grands
les grandes maisons d'édition où on va
avoir une mise en avant facile
si je pense que dans toutes les
librairies ou vous avez un libraire
curieux vous pouvez toujours trouver les
éditions la jeannie parce que j'ai aussi
la joie ni mais voilà il faut être
curieux et puis c'est une collaboration
aussi parce que parfois on a on a des
des éditeurs qui viennent nous présenter
leur livre c'est vraiment un travail en
équipe on aime j'aurais évoque
l'ensemble de la chaîne du livre ici
avec un souci de produire peu mais en
qualité mais invalidée essais des
éditeurs qui qui
s'est compliqué pour eux ou pas quand on
cherche justement pas en parler votre
jean charles aussi vite et d'éditeur
mais
non c'est vrai ah oui c'est une équipe
compliquée c'est très compliqué puisque
d'abord pour le pôle d'éditeurs il faut
retomber sur des libraires passionnés et
il y en a mais il n'ya pas que des
libraires passionnés donc oui et des
vendeurs des livres quand on les
tribunes quand on trouve un livre un
passionné en décomptant et l'avait
visiblement aux éditions devait pure ils
ont trouvé avec vous une formidable
ambassadrice donc ça c'est bien ce que
vous mettez vraiment les rues en valeur
d'accepter le présentoir vous défendez
des choses où visiblement les avais lu
vous connaissez les trucs donc l'un est
vrai que pour l'éditeur ça facilite pas
face à la vie est compliquée
économiquement mais mais c'est vrai que
quand on a la chance d'avoir des
partenaires qui jouent le jeu qui
défendent qui met le livre en valeur
avec tout ce qu'il a d'intéressant qui
sont capables d'expliquer au niveau au
client au lecteur ce que ce qu'ils vont
trouver à quel point c'est bien quel
point c'était difficile à quel point
c'est beau c'est vrai que il ya un vrai
conseil là c'est juste ça c'est vraiment
chouette
grands auteurs
sans arrêt
je crois qu'à noël il ya quasiment trois
livres de cuisine qui sortent par jour
mais ces cd livres hyper classique et là
c'est c'est comme une alternative sont
assez génial là-haut livres de cuisine
pas différent troisième il est comme ça
on a un vrai conseil original et ça
c'est vraiment chouette alors est ce
qu'on parle de de pierre boucher ray
alors pierre que vous serrez bien
repoussé reste un commandant de police
qui a pris sa retraite moi comme tous
les flics un peu tôt à mon goût mais il
ya bien des
58 54 55 elles sont là alors où au-delà
du problème politique faisait au moins
dire qu'il y en a qu ils prennent leur
retraite qui se met à écrire des bons
livres et donc pierre poussière et il
est très très très bon auteur dé pas
chez nous c'est pour ça que la nature et
édition filature et il est également
aussi publié aux éditions palémon il a
eu le prix du quai des orfèvres ya
quelques années prix du quai des
orfèvres ir qui vient est en cours de
tournage ils font un remake à partir ce
film d'olivier marchal qui met ça en
scène dacca s'associe ainsi à fric voilà
le si l'ancien flic est donc dans sa vie
il a été notamment en poste à la
pj de versailles
à la brigade quelque chose de très
important c'est un passage obligé pour
tous les grands flics c'est de passer
par versailles c'est vraiment une
oui quelque chose de très important
c'est juste en dessous du l'ancien 36 av
mais c'était vraiment un truc vachement
bien donc il était là et puis il est
devenu aussi après l'appel attaché de
sécurité intérieure cdc les policiers
qui sont dans les ambassades et sont
censés s'occuper de tout la sécurité
intérieure dhs en tout cas des français
dans ces pays là donc lui claire
bouchard elle était en poste dans
beaucoup de pays il a été en poste dans
les pays pays d'asile a été un an nous
béquille ce temps il a été en irak il a
été dans des pays où ça bougerait e et
ressort de tout ça et bien notamment
ceux se livrent la consule assassiné où
il part 2
de l'idée qu'une
la consul de france a été assassiné dans
une ambassade d'un pays imaginaire mais
qu'on arrive à peu près à avoir à peu
près où ça peut se trouver on doit pas
être très loin de la biélorussie effacer
un peu de pays voilà et tous ces pays
qui connaît bien et l'intrigué est assez
amusant parce que là du coup on découvre
toute la vie d'une ambassade qui n'est
pas l'ambassade de washington où
l'ambassade eux
le de moscou va qui sont des structures
un peu plus petit avec mes des
problématiques sont différentes
et puis une vie pour les français pour
tous les gens qui tournent autour qui
essayent de rentrer en france veulent à
cesser tout à fait tout à fait
passionnant et à gérer donc ça s'appelle
la consule à sa saisine et ses filatures
voilà il ya wuala alors voilà c'est tout
c'est en revanche c'est chez nous les
éditions très bonne édition très bonne
édition avec royer incroyable de talent
et d'ailleurs et
c'est le pendant de pierre fouchenneret
puisque pierre boucher avait été
commandant de police et lui était
colonel de gendarmerie parce que c'est
un les attacher des écopes l'intérieur
il ya des gendarmes et policiers voient
là il m'a vu des confidences de temps en
temps voilà il y a toujours des visages
sur des conflits et les huit tribunaux
donc colonel de gendarmerie il a été en
poste pendant quatre ans au cameroun
comme attaché de sécurité intérieure et
alors là lui il a vraiment découvert et
vu le cameroun il nous en fait une
présentation qui pour le moins de ne pas
envie d'aller au cameroun du tout
et quand j'ai vu de manuscrits plus à me
retourner comme une idée j'ai adoré le
cameroun j'ai passé quatre ans mais oui
je sais que je pourrai plus attendue du
ca va maintenant je regrette toute la
question la plein d'autres pays à
visiter
et là c'est l'histoire d'un jeune d'un
jeune ingénieur français y un peu en
rupture de tout en france et qui un peu
à la mode il tient une ong qui me
propose un boulot au cameroun je vais y
aller et ne sait absolument ils sont à
peine ou et le cameroun sur une carte du
monde donc il arrive là-bas tout ou naïf
et c'est le premier soir va boire un
coup dans une boîte de nuit il se fait
dépouiller ce massacre et on lui vole
tous etc
terrorisé il veut repartir et là il
tombe heureusement sur un attaché de
sécurité intérieure dans lequel on
reconnaît l'auteur exclusivement qui vit
maintenant mais le cameroun c'est
beaucoup mieux que ça vous êtes fait
agresser bon femmes et puis voilà il va
arriver là et il doit aller dans le sud
du cameroun est ce que peu de gens ça
c'est qu' aucun mot nien parti
sécessionniste anglophones qui a même
créé un pays complètement fantoche que
personne ne reconnaît mais qui lutte de
façon très violente contre le contre le
pouvoir et pouvoir qu'il n'a pas que des
qualités un peu le billard quand même
pas bons mais prise mais du coup il a
fait un petit moment voilà l idéal
filature mais c'est une lutte à mort
entre les sécessionnistes anglophone et
le pouvoir est au milieu de sa vie à la
population qui un peu meurtri plus qu'il
en retire donc ça va être une lente un
an voyage peut être par moments une
longue descente aux enfers parce que il
ya les sécessionnistes anglophone 100
sont dirigés par une sorte de fou
furieux qui n'est pas sans rappeler le
colonel la cure qui dans le
riz le film le ça va me revenir enfin
bref
c'est terrible cette perte de mémoire
enfin bref que l'amérique urs pour tous
les gens qui se dessine et il s'en va
parler apocalypse
voilà et voilà et donc c'est très très
bien et puis il tombe sur les tombes
aussi amoureux d'une d'une belle belle
camerounaise bamiléké et voilà ça c'est
un masque bamiléké wallace avait voilà
ça veut dire ça veut dire exactement
exactement exactement un malheur peine
peur terreur voilà car ce que je sais
c'est vrai mais c'est parce que lui il
donne le vent les significations laisse
donc à cette dire ça oui oui c'est tout
à fait tout à fait passionnant
qu'on passe à vous deux grosses secondes
contre
vallée alors d'accord
c'est vrai moi je j'ai lu cet été un
livre qui m'a énormément plu qui
s'appelle bartleby le scribe paru chez
chez folio et c'est qu'elle est l'auteur
c'est herman melville man melville
évidemment on le connaît pour son fameux
moby dick et on peut dire que finalement
l'ombre géante de la baleine là un petit
peu
éclipsé beaucoup des nouvelles de
melville qui sont pas du tout connu
alors il ya eu cet automne l'intégrale
des nouvelle de melville qui a été
publié de nouveaux traduit c'était là au
mois de novembre et finalement c'est
vrai que ces nouvelles sont pas très
connus alors dans cette nouvelle c'est
un petit texte très très court mais
vraiment génial absolument
extraordinaire donc on a bartelby c'est
un homme sans qualités sans référence
100 possessions sans passé sans futur
enfin il est il est très très
particulier on est dans le wall street
des années 1850 et il est employé en
tant que co piste dans un cabinet
juridique et son employeur va lui
demander un certain nombre de taff et au
fur et à mesure de l'histoire enfin de
la nouvelle est bien bartelby prenons ce
plus en plus la phrase suivante i would
prefer not je ne préférerais ne pas où
j'aimerais mieux pas et donc il ya cette
phrase comme sabrina minutes ce qui
revient d'ailleurs celui qui bloque
faire et qu'il a lu à l'audience
maintenant c'est celui qui m'a offert ce
livre on
n'arrête pas tous les deux de se
raconter de blaguer autour de cette
phrase je prenne j'aimerais mieux pas je
crois que tous les lecteurs de ce livre
ensuite reprennent cette phrase je vous
en dis pas plus parce qu'elle est très
énigmatique mais il ya derrière cette
phrase évidemment toute la critique vous
de l'absurdité des tâches
administratives
du processus de l'aliénation d'un
travail c'est un petit livre très très
fort très étrange et si on passait aux
sardines alors
ça n'a rien à voir celle des recettes
oui mais il ya des recettes il ya tout
un beau livre c'est un lien parfait que
la baleine qui manque pourtant pas de
sardines mais bon et donc là c'est un
très beau livre
si on marque presque marque reste que tu
nettement se connaissaient pas on se
connaissait pas épuisé croisé l'éditeur
c'est un type charmant qui vient de
reprendre cette maison d'édition et qui
totalise
et alors il fait le tour sur le monde de
la sardine à l'ariane et à l'histoire de
la sardine la taille de la sardine tout
le monde sait qui est une différence
dans la sardine de militaires année la
sardine de l'atlantique sardines de
l'atlantique sont délicieuses mais qui
deviennent trop grosse pour entrer dans
les boîtes oui ils sont parce qu'avant
on était quasiment cinq ou six sardines
maintenant ils arrivent à peine à mettre
cap haskell
est alors qu'en méditerranée ils ont un
problème c'est qu'elles sont trop
petites
mais voilà je peux le port de marseille
ça ne risque plus un disque cru douchez
pas de preneur mais il ya notamment
l'explication sur la sardine qui bouche
le port de marseille il ya bien
évidemment un truc sur les diacres sur
les boîtes de sardines les recettes il
ya une d'une quinzaine de recettes c'est
fait par des séries de
sardines millésimées par exemple
l'espace explique oui parce que la
sardine ça se confie un peu dans la
boîte en fait si on les garde pour les
garder des années en fait moi je retire
toujours la salle arrête de la sardine à
l'huile oui oui à des gougnafiers qui la
mange
mieux mais si vous mangez la la tomate
mais dont la sardine millésimé vous
faites au début de phase iia des
bouillons t'es pas là on est 3e de la
poule vous savez après faut la mettre
dans l'eau chaude vous allez voir notre
monde
tomates sur la peau voilà alors c'est
plein de belles photos et c'est vraiment
plein de clins d'oeil et sa droite ça
fait vraiment le tour sur la sardine
après je pense que plus personne
pourrait il ya plus rien à écrire sur
les sardines à part ça quoi tout est là
tout est dedans donc servi nos éditions
marque crès voilà un beau livre et un
mode rené fallet alors on est peut-être
un peu oublié et bas hélas alors tout le
monde le connaît parce que c'est le seul
auteur de la soupe aux choux gras alors
du coup comme le film repasse un des
films qui repasse le plus avec la grande
vadrouille la soupe aux choux les
enfants adorent nous on adore mais avant
d'être un film
devenu culte c'est vraiment un grand et
créer un langage grand coq à leur voix
qui maîtrise parfaitement bien là bien
la langue qui adorait le français grand
copain d'un brassens grand copain de
brassens était vraiment est extrêmement
extrêmement amis et ça c'est son journal
et il est aussi le l'oncle d'un auteur
qui est que vous connaissez je crois que
gérard pussey
qu'a publié chez nous un livre rien dit
du formidable auteur oui quel prix elle
nimier prix dont le prix du premier
roman etc et c'est ainsi ce journal de
rené fallet alors c'est un journaliste
de
d'anecdotes et puis deux sortes de
d'aphorismes et de choses et on sent
quand même si rené fallet une sorte de
par moments un peu de désespérance quoi
il est est paru pendant une vision assez
noir enfin quatre étaient un peu anar un
peu un peu anar un peu revenu tout un
peu restée à peu déçu par l'impro
d'humanité parce que même quand il a
coaché reçoit le prix interallié c'est
quand même un très beau prix il est pas
si qu'autant que ça parce qu'il dit ben
c'est pas si ce roman là qu'il méritait
c'était le précédent chaque fois il a
toujours un petit côté pour ça que c'est
génial et les journaux abbas et c'est
vraiment puis sas picore alors c'est un
peu comme dans la nouvelle ça se lit
vite mais ça ça se lit vite aussi parce
que ça veut dire que tout me revient
aujourd'hui exactement
et ça c'est très bien je pense au
journal aussi de delacroix oui
oui oui il ya des missions c'est pas
c'est pas très sympa une vision très
joyeuse très petit mais c'est surtout
pas une vision très à la mode parce
qu'il y là il adore les femmes il n'en
parle mais de façon assez parlants assez
assez truculent que
j'allais pas dans le féminisme exacerbé
des morts quoi dans les 80 éléments 83
est évidemment assez jeune et sa femme
est toujours face à veuve pardon et est
toujours là et vient elle aussi de
sortir un bouquin
mais c'est bien de parler c'est vraiment
quelque chose à
redécouvrir et qu'ils ont quelques mieux
littérature et on parle parfois c'est
vrai qu'il ya des auteurs comme ça il ya
un peu oublié parfois c'est bien de
découvrir quoi tdc maisons de retraite
et oui je voulais pas ça c'est chez vous
donc voilà vous êtes modeste
mais c'est jean-françois près qu'on
avait une plaisir data liens de recevoir
ici pour son précédent roman c'est à
saint jean françois perret le codé parce
que tu as initié a été chroniqueur
hippique specis des chevaux et là c'est
bon ça dans ce roman en dessous alors
c'est d'actualité à batna pendant la
campagne électorale il ya un tueur ac un
tueur à gages qui est mandaté pour
désigner les candidats et alors en fait
tout cela il ya du boulot mais on
s'écoute on voit qu'à la fin qui est
richard hill qui l'a mandaté mais c'est
sera bien bien bien au retour en arrière
tout le temps avec le ça se passe entre
paris et le qatar une câblerie il est
une magnifique course
d'enduro dessablage fallon un truc ça
dès le grand prix d'amérique c'est non
le prix de la
maintenance du qatar une grande prise et
ils ont des très beaux chevaux là bas
ben voila ca deaux qui s'appelle donc
band sauce et de jean-françois près et
c'est aux éditions la joie ni est ce que
je peux dire juste un petit bac oui sur
alors ça c'est ça c'est une vraie
curiosité
j'en fait hier
auteur qui à 80 ans je crois il m'en
voudra pas là peut-être que 79 ans
disons entre 79 et 80 qui a écrit 57
roman quotas un de ses romans marche pas
bien ils en vendent 90001 oui oui donc
voyez donc tiens moi j'aimerais bien
avoir un roman qui marchait bien voilà
hélas il n'est pas chez nous et est il à
son son héroïne qui était une capitaine
de police ou peut-être maintenant
commandant
mary lester qui se baladent
principalement en bretagne est un peu
dans tous les lieux mais on est à des
années lumières de 2,7
de l'édition parfois trop régionalisme
on tombe sur des bouquins dans chaque
endroit de vacances où là c'est
uniquement les trois adresses de la
ville et c'est là c'est simplement
historiquement ça se passe là c'est la
cedh à belle-ile hélas espace à
belle-ile qui est pour moi le plus bel
ont marre et on donne donc voilà c'est
pour ça je pouvais pas
mais ne pas en parler et c'est toujours
passionnant quoi et c'est son 57e libre
57e roman ils imaginent et ces voix là
j'en fais là vous devez
vraiment je vous la fais vous régaler
parce que c'est fait vraiment
c'est très sympa avec lui laissa sur la
bretagne
merci à vous merci infiniment merci
beaucoup c'est la classique et donc je
rappelle librairie le livre bleu à
présent treuil à versailles et c'est là
qu'on trouve notamment passé édition
formidables qui sont les éditions et
pure et les éditions thibert
merci beaucoup jean charles et merci
pour ces conseils formidable on est ravi
bah oui je crois
j'aimerais mieux pas merci beaucoup et à
trèbes eu lieu très vite on va très vite
fiona de votre site et de d'achat non
parce que si vite et en librairie abbas
et bien merci beaucoup